[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about how
to use the singular value decomposition
to compute the principal component
analysis which gives you a statistical
decomposition of of data into its
directions of principle of maximum
variation and minimum variation okay so
you can decompose a data set into kind
of these these principal component
directions where you have the most
variance in the data and then
hierarchically you know less and less
and less variance of the data good and
we tried it on this simple example where
we know the answer so now we're going to
look at this other example that I like a
lot this is the ovarian cancer data set
so this is a built-in data set in MATLAB
that you can now load in this comma
separated variable list the CSV file
again you can download it at data
book.com data book u-dub com this
lecture follow section 1.5 of our our
new book data-driven science and
engineering and so here what we're going
to do this is actually a really really
interesting data set this ovarian cancer
data set
what you have is essentially a 216 216
by 4,000 sized matrix okay and what this
is the 216 dimension these are 216
individual patients and the 4,000
dimension these are 4,000 genetic
markers that are measured for every
single one of those patients so if I
look at the first row those are 4,000
genetic markers for that patient that
first patient and what's also
interesting is that these patients are
broken up into groups so that the first
half have ovarian cancer so cancer and
the second half have no cancer okay and
so what we're going to be able to do is
use kind of factor analysis or principal
components analysis rather the SVD to
decompose this big data this high
dimensional gene data into key
factors that will allow us to understand
kind of what drives cancer versus not
cancer in these 216 patients okay now
this is really just kind of a toy
example still it's a little bit closer
to the real world but there's you know a
lot of things you have to do to be
careful if you were actually going to
use this so so this is just kind of an
illustration okay now 4000 variables are
far too many for me to visualize and to
plot and to understand kind of the
relationships of these variables and how
they drive these outcomes and so with
the principal component analysis or the
SVD are going to allow us to do is
essentially learn kind of eigen genetic
sequences so if I SVD this big X matrix
then I would get a 216 by 216 u matrix a
diagonal Sigma matrix and V would have
216 by by 4,000 4,000 columns and each
row of V would be essentially an eigen
gene sequence it's kind of the gene
sequence that captures most of the
variation among these 216 patients the
second one would be the second most
variation eigen gene sequence and what's
neat is that instead of visualizing all
4,000 dimensions of these patients
genetic sequence what I can do is I can
plot just the first few eigen gene
sequences for each patient and so
instead of this 4000 dimensional space I
can project down into a low dimensional
space in terms of principal component
one principal component two and
principal component three and if I'm
lucky then the patients that do and
don't have cancer might cluster in this
space and that would give me information
about how I could then understand what's
different about them what's the same how
to maybe predict cancer in a new patient
something like that okay so let's run
this example we're gonna load the
ovarian cancer data set we also are
going to learn the groups so in addition
to this big matrix of observations
in this OBS matrix we also have a vector
of labels
that's 216 tall and it basically says
they have cancer or they don't have
cancer so the first half is yes the
second half is now okay and we're going
to take this X matrix this OB s V does
this observation matrix and we're going
to compute its SVD just like before and
we're gonna plot the cancer and
non-cancer patients in those first three
principal components okay so so that's
what we're gonna do before we do that
scatter plot let's just look at the
actual singular values of this data set
so these are the the log of the diagonal
elements of Sigma and this is the
cumulative sum to show how much variance
is captured by the first are our
singular vectors and this is exactly
what I want to see when I compute the
SVD of a data matrix notice that there
is this massive energetic group of only
a few singular values that capture a
huge portion of the energy or variance
of the data set so you have this large
portion of structure and then you have a
relatively fast roll-off where there's
very little information down here so
capturing keeping only the first three
or five or ten of these singular values
and singular vectors you're going to
capture a large portion of the variance
between all of these patients genetic
information and you can see here even if
you only capture the first singular
vector you'd have about 55 percent of
the of the variance of this data matrix
so that's that's really promising so now
what we're gonna do is we're going to
take our observation matrix this this x
matrix and we're gonna project it into
the first three principal components so
basically I'm going to take these first
three rows of V transpose kind of V 1 V
2 V 3 so this is a 3 by 4,000 and for
every patient I'm just going to take
their genetic sequence and take the dot
product with these 3 rows and I'm going
to get 3 numbers out and those 3 numbers
are what I'm going to plot and these
principal component one two and three
and I'm gonna plot different symbols for
the patients with cancer and without
cancer based on their group and here's
what we have in the plot so you can see
that the X's are the patient with cancer
the circles are the patients without
cancer and very nicely this data
actually does kind of separate in these
principal component directions so you
get reasonably good separation in these
first three principal components and if
I included let's say you know the first
five or ten or twenty I probably would
get even better separation of those two
categories but this provides a low
dimensional human interpretable way of
understanding this very high dimensional
genetic information because I'm
projecting into this low dimensional
kind of eigen genetic space where I can
plot how these distributions fall out
okay so principal components is super
useful for visualizing high dimensional
data that has some statistical
distribution and using it to understand
kind of the structure of that low
dimensional the low dimensional
structure about data okay thank you